en física los conceptos del trabajo y
potencia sirven para entender y explicar
muchas cosas en nuestro universo
empecemos con el trabajo el trabajo
positivo es la energía que ponemos en un
sistema y el trabajo negativo es la
energía que se transfiere en sentido
contrario piensa en el trabajo positivo
como el dinero que se suma a tu cuenta
bancaria y trabajo negativo como el
dinero que sacas en el sistema métrico
el trabajo y la energía se miden en
jules como ejemplo veamos este hermoso y
viejo reloj mecánico de pie transferimos
energía al reloj cuando le damos cuerda
para levantar los pesados cilindros
metálicos el reloj al hacerlo
realizamos trabajo positivo agregando
energía al reloj energía que se almacena
como energía potencial gravitatoria
podemos calcular la cantidad de trabajo
hecho al multiplicar la fuerza que
aplicamos por la distancia sobre la que
aplicamos la fuerza para levantar los
cilindros metálicos necesitamos aplicar
una fuerza igual a su peso esto es igual
a la fuerza de gravedad que empuja hacia
abajo los cilindros
estos cilindros pesan 300 newtons lo que
es bastante pesado tanto como un niño
pequeño y si los levantamos medio metro
entonces son 300 minutos por medio metro
o 150 jules de trabajo la potencia es la
velocidad a la que se transfiere la
energía cuando decimos velocidad
queremos decir la cantidad de energía
transferida por unidad de tiempo en el
sistema métrico la potencia se mide en
jules por segundo o watts el término
vatio o watts viene de james watt quien
propuso el concepto de caballos de
potencia para medir la cantidad de
potencia producida por un caballo de
carga típico james watt fue el inventor
de las máquinas de vapor industriales y
quería que sus clientes potenciales
pudieran hacer comparaciones entre sus
máquinas de vapor y una cantidad
familiar la potencia que podían obtener
de una bestia de carga fue una idea tan
útil que la unidad del sistema métrico
de potencia el vatio o watts fue acuñada
en honor de james watt siguiendo los
pasos de james watt comparemos la
cantidad de potencia requerida para que
este reloj de pie funcione con la
potencia que necesitaría
para encender un foco de 100 vatios
podemos medir la potencia que una
persona emplea para darle cuerda al
reloj dividiendo la cantidad de trabajo
realizado por el tiempo que toma hacerlo
sin levantar las pesas toma un minuto o
60 segundos son 150 jules divididos por
60 segundos o 2.5 jules por segundo de
trabajo estás agregando energía al reloj
a una tasa de 25 vatios necesitarías una
velocidad 40 veces mayor para encender
un foco de 100 vatios antes de dejar que
el reloj funcione la energía se almacena
como energía potencial gravitatoria de
los cilindros es como tu cuenta bancaria
cuando acabas de depositar dinero pero
si dejas que el reloj se ponga en marcha
los cilindros se mueven lentamente hacia
abajo la energía se va del reloj de
hecho cuando los cilindros llegan al
fondo toda la energía que pusimos se
habrá acabado entonces cuánta potencia
usa el reloj es decir cuántos jules de
energía por segundo se van del reloj si
los cilindros necesitan cinco días para
regresar a su posición original lo
podemos calcular porque ya sabemos
cuánto trabajo hacemos cuando levantamos
los cilindros 150 jules pero esta vez
tomó 5 días en vez de un minuto 5 días
es 5 por 24 x 60 x 60 una vez más o 432
mil segundos entonces dividimos el
trabajo realizado por el tiempo y la
respuesta es cerca de 0 0 0035 jules por
segundo o cerca de 0 35 mil vatios
eso es una diminuta cantidad de potencia
este reloj usa tan poca potencia que
podrías tener casi 300 mil relojes
funcionando con la misma potencia
requerida para encender un foco de 100
vatios
así es podrías tener un reloj
funcionando en cada casa en una ciudad
mediana con esa potencia sin duda es una
conclusión bastante sorprendente y
conociendo el trabajo y la potencia la
podemos calcular